hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the st. Louis rapid
and blitz the third stop on the grand
chest tour it was the exciting event
probably the most exciting rapid a blitz
event we've had since inception that we
had so much fun with it we hope you as
an audience enjoyed it as well
we were regarded by these fantastic
players over the five days first of all
I'd like to thank Ellie and the world
chess Hall of Fame for hosting us what a
spectacular venue thank you so much
Shannon and everyone who puts on such a
great show I'd also like to thank Jeanie
dr. Jeanne Sinquefield and Rex for once
again making this special for us without
such great patrons of the game we would
not have the miracle that is here in st.
Louis ten years and running may there be
10 more years much like this one the
vision for the Grantchester came about
because of one garry kasparov he is not
here I hope he is watching from
somewhere he usually is paying very
close attention but without that
visionary his ideas his energy is
passion and his support we would not be
able to do this so Gary wherever you are
Gary Kasparov thank you so much
[Applause]
of course the Grantchester has a
wonderful staff micarta Kowski Graham
Jorgensen now campaign in London and of
course Tony rich everyone making sure
that the whole events as events are
well-oiled machines and the vision that
you the new playoff format you know I
love NBA basketball Mike this was
exciting with four tournaments and then
we get the four finalists going to
London it's changed the whole thing and
it's made it very exciting so kudos and
a warm hand for the visionaries who came
up with this new format thank you we're
collaborating overseas with two other
cities two other great cities first of
all in Paris Jilla Ben Hauser with
Colliers International and also Vivendi
sponsoring the events as well beautiful
studio that they run the event in in
Paris and also Yan kilohertz with your
next move in Levin in Belgium
spectacular venue as well I guess I
could repeat that over and over again
because it's always world-class so we
want to thank those two great European
cities was to lights up the events
and with that I will introduce a man who
needs no introduction executive director
of the Chess Club
Tony rich Thank You breeze so as Maurice
alluded to we are celebrating our 10
year anniversary at the st. Louis chess
club it's been a decade since we opened
the doors across the street from here
and you know little but I have known
back then that we'd all sitting here
today with these great luminaries of the
game you know our first year that the
club was open we had some nice weekend
tournaments we had a couple of
grandmasters visit the Chess Club the
next year we added the US and the
Women's Championship the next year the
Junior Championship fast forward we've
added the grand chest tour now three
years ago and you know I get asked the
question a lot what would have happened
you know did you plan all of this you
know would you have guessed all this was
going to happen and the answer to that
is a resounding no it's been because of
the the generosity of all of our
sponsors it's been because of dr.
Jeannie and Rex Sinquefield but most
importantly it's been because of all of
the great players who have provided some
amazing chess over the years thank you
all very much and thank you all as well
for joining us I mentioned earlier one
of the great patrons of this event and
I'm gonna have her come up and introduce
her hubby dr. Jeannie Singh I'm so happy
to see you guys sorry you couldn't all
win shout out hey Carl it's sea water
here for people who lived here and Louis
they tend to win you know when Rex and I
are always very competitive people so he
started this chess club and started
having the highest-rated tournaments in
the world and the best players from all
over so I got boy scouts the chess
start chess merit badge and we're up to
180,000 fans
but obviously without you guys and these
tournaments there's no point for having
fans so here we go The Godfather is just
Godfather huh oh no I'm talking about so
well I want to thank first of all all
the players what an exciting match you
gave us and then the commentators Yasir
Jennifer Maurice Peter Merrill Alejandro
and who did I leave out Christian I'm
sorry Christian a late Christian sorry
so all you people are just amazing I
always say our commentating team is so
good that they alone they by themselves
or a reason to have a great chess match
and I want to thank of course joy who
makes everything run smoothly I can
fully understand why around Christmas
time everybody jumps for joy so I want
to thank the Chess Club staff the Hall
of Fame Shannon and Randy Kincaid Tami
Mosel Leonard all of you people that
supply the oxygen for these productions
and produce what is I believe the finest
sports production of any sport in the
world and that goes with the finest
commentary team on top of it
so thank you all very much and to Carl
you had an amazing tournament any event
is exciting if you are in it and it's
especially exciting if you're winning it
and so you created a lot of excitement
the last few days and congratulations
and thank you and you've already secured
one of the four spots in London so the
way to go we we wish you the best of
luck there and now one of the other
people I would like to introduce is the
man who makes st. Louis County run
smoothly the county executive Steve
stinger
well thank you all very much it is a
real honor to be with you this evening
and as the 2018 rapid blitz tournament
closes we salute all of the competitors
and congratulate the winners who emerge
from these contests as the finest
players in the game and we thank Rex and
dr. Jeanne Ziegfeld for promoting the
great game of chess and our hometown the
entire st. Louis region benefited from
this event along with the other chess
tournaments held here at the world chess
Hall of Fame thank you thank you and
indeed these games serve to reinforce
our region's status as the international
headquarters of child and I'll tell you
as the county executive and particularly
impressed by the enthusiasm that you
drive particularly with our young people
and how our young people are showing
such enthusiasm for chess this game
enhances classroom learning by teaching
kids the value of critical thinking
analytical thinking setting goals and
showing sportsmanship and we really
appreciate that in our community and of
course they have fun while there again I
appreciate in the ceremony and I thank
the sick fields for their leadership in
support of our community and you guys
you're fantastic thank you very much
[Applause]
well like I said this event was truly
the most exciting of all the events
we've seen events if someone runs away
with it and that's pretty cool to watch
a dominant player that's always exciting
but to watch players go back and forth
slugging it out having us on the edges
of our seats we're looking for the trend
who's winning it who's the best player
and then that person gets knocked down
and it's somebody else and they really
they were just leapfrogging each other
at the top we did not know who was going
to win until literally the
second-to-last round and that makes for
a very exciting event and so these
players you all see here these these
gentlemen I think I can call you guys
that gentleman right some of you at
least these gentlemen really showed
their genius their talent their
incredible preparation their
determination their fighting spirit so
we are excited to be able to watch you
and I hope you appreciate how much we
are fans watching you I might be a
compensator but I'm a fan first and
which is why I get so excited watching
so before I highlight three of the
players please give a big hand to our
participants the grandmasters
[Applause]
well deserved we are so excited to have
you each and every single time here in
st. Louis and playing in all these
spectacular events but three players
stood out in this event the Grantchester
of course began in Louisville where
Grand Master Wesley so won first place
in Paris Grandmaster Nakamura the honors
there
oh this tournament we have in third
place it's a player who gave it a great
run he didn't do great in Paris and
Lubin like he wanted to and me before
the tournament oh it's told me one of
the interviews he said I just changed my
strategy I decided be aggressive I'm
gonna go for and he was aggressive and
play some awesome games very in third
place
[Applause]
this Edmond was four points behind four
points is a lot to try to make up but in
the Blitz
this is after the rapid but in the Blitz
he started winning game after game after
game one point he won three in a row to
make it five wins out of seven games and
he came back the next day and one four
five four times
unfortunately he won he lost one game
where he got a little excited he
sacrifice a piece he figured I think so
Faline he could do whatever he wanted
but this game it just didn't quite work
but ten wins and only one loss in all
those 18 games an absurd number of wins
fantastic performance good enough for a
second place from France grandmaster
Maxine
[Applause]
but one champion that's how we roll here
in st. Louis
no ties but we'd have to arm-wrestle to
tie break if necessary but we did not
have to because this gentleman took it
all he had not won in a while an
international event yeah I don't think
actually ever wanted in that
international event here in st. Louis
that rubbed it the wrong way he's won
many championships here
four-time US Champion he's won Blitz
events certainly a lot of matchups but
to win with all the all-stars that he's
used to playing against was something
that he wanted to take care of here in
st. Louis
certainly one in Paris a couple of years
ago he also came back to win in Paris
this year but he has made it an
impressive in this field very hard to do
back back championship and so our
champion for the 2018 st. Louis rabbit
and blitz master
[Applause]
I know this is a proud moment for you so
I will give you the opportunity to say a
few words um well first of all
we'll see
thank you all right we will look for
that well the color you do have a
formality and that is to accept the
winner's trophy so I will invite dr.
Jeannie Singh field a directs to give
you the trophy and certainly we will
take some pictures of the winner
and don't leave because I heard there's
a rumor that there's a big old chick oh
here we go
got your name on it I'm not sure if you
can cash this one but congratulations
once again hikaru proud moment for him
of course
Finnegan's Louis Hikaru has been here
since the inception he is the thing the
longest participating Grandmaster in
these events he was here nine years ago
for the first time and has been a
stalwart ever since and a great
supporter of the club of course so it's
a win we're very happy to see you in
here in st. Louis akaru well that is
that we do have multiple events still to
think about tomorrow it will be ultimate
moves and we'll have I believe non
grandmaster Rex Sinquefield will be
playing along with his son Randy Singh
field
I'm starting the trash-talking early
because the players will be relaxed and
be able to talk be able to bring out
their best lines I hope you guys have
created some new ones for this year no
way we are picking they'll be picking
teams and someone kind of good will be
joining us he has a little extra town
his name happens to be magnus carlsen
and he will be playing in the event and
I think Peter Svidler is going to join
as well in order to even things out so
that should be a ton of fun of course
once ultimate moves is over then we'll
get on to classical chess we'll have the
opening ceremony for that in a couple of
days for the Sinquefield cup and again
Magnus will be the [ __ ] part in that it
serie and going on for folks thank you
again players thank you the World Chess
Hall of Fame thank you this chess club
dr. Jeanne Singh field
thank you spec nose and thank you as we
really reach you and look forward again
starting tomorrow right here
one o'clock that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]